هو أن ليز تروس تم انتخابها
كقائدة للحزب المحافظ والوحدوي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، شكرًا لك سيدي جراهام ، إنه لشرف كبير
أن يتم انتخابك
كزعيم للحزب المحافظ
والوحدوي
في هذه الحملة القيادية التي قمت
بحملتها بصفتي محافظًا و  سأحكم
كمحافظ وأصدقائي نحتاج إلى إظهار أننا
سنقدم
على مدار العامين المقبلين
العالم بأسره يواجهه وكل
أوروبا تواجه قدرًا هائلاً من
المشاكل ولكن في كل شيء هناك
عاصفة تتجمع في  بريطانيا
وإنه لأمر غير عادي ،
فقد قمنا بإضرابات في كل مكان تقريبًا
في نظام القطارات ، والنظام البريدي ،
والمحامين الذين كنا يجمعناهم ، وتسميهم
ما يسمونه ، ومن المذهل
أن لدينا ، والأهم من ذلك ، إمكانية حدوث
قدر هائل من الاضطرابات الاجتماعية
بسبب
الكهرباء والغاز
[الموسيقى
] سأقدم خطة لخفض الضرائب
وتنمية
اقتصادنا ، وسأعمل على حل أزمة الطاقة التي
تتعامل مع فواتير الطاقة لدى الناس ، ولكن
أيضًا التعامل مع المدى الطويل
لدينا بشأن إمدادات الطاقة
[موسيقى]
هذه أزمة يجب
التحدث عنها في جميع أنحاء العالم وليس طرفًا واحدًا فقط ،
وأنا أعلم
أننا سنقدم خدماتنا وسنقدمها وسنقدم نصراً عظيماً
للحزب المحافظ  في عام
2024 شكرا لك